now before the festival of Passover
Jesus knew that his hour had come to
depart from this world and go to the
father having loved his own who were in
the world he loved them to the end the
devil had already put it into the heart
of Judas son of Simon Iscariot to betray
him and during supper Jesus knowing that
the father had given all things into his
hands and that he had come from God and
was going to God got up from the table
took off his outer robe and tied a towel
around himself then he poured water into
a basin and began to wash the disciples
feet and to wipe them with the towel
that was tied around him he came to
Simon Peter who said to him Lord are you
going to wash my feet jesus answered you
do not know now what I am doing but
later you will understand Peter said to
him you will never wash my feet jesus
answered unless I wash you you have no
share with me Simon Peter said to him
Lord not my feet only but also my hands
and my head jesus said to him one who
has bathed does not need to wash except
for the feet but is entirely clean and
you are clean though not all of you for
he knew who was to betray him for this
reason he said not all of you are clean
after he had washed their feet had put
on his robe and had returned to the
table he said to them do you know what
we've done to you you call me teacher
and Lord and you are right for that is
what I am so I your Lord and teacher
have washed your feet you also ought to
wash one another's feet for I have set
you an example that you should also do
I have done to you very truly I tell you
servants are not greater than their
master nor our messenger is greater than
the one who sent them if you know these
things you are blessed if you do them I
am NOT speaking of all of you I know
whom I have chosen but it is to fulfill
the scripture the one who ate my bread
has lifted his heel against me I tell
you this now before it occurs so that
when it occurs you may believe that I am
he very truly I tell you whoever
receives one whom I send receives me and
whoever receives me receives him who
sent to me
John 13 The Last Supper recalls in some
ways the other accounts the Last Supper
but is so strikingly different starts
out with that notion of the hour that
now is beginning at the end of the
fourth gospel it's a very long very long
with many speeches yeah chapters on end
and it begins with this this episode of
Jesus at dinner with his disciples at a
slightly different time from what we
find in the synoptic Gospels right
because they are he's celebrating a
Passover meal and here he has to be
dining the day before the Passover meal
is celebrated because he dies the time
of the Passover lamb yep is sacrifice
according to chapter 19 so we have that
difference with the synoptic Gospels but
the major difference is the absence of
any account of a the institution of the
Eucharist no there's no breaking of the
bread no reference to the the cup whose
blood is whose wine is pulled out and
the symbol of the blood poured out to
establish a new covenant the kind of
language we get in all three Synoptics
and also at all
you know first corinthians so that's a
striking difference and that's always
intrigued me
I think it's intrigued that the whole
history of Johanna in scholarship is
there a hidden allusion to the Eucharist
here or is it something that John wants
to avoid somewhere there well that's a
problem I don't know if that's a huge
problem to which I have come down firmly
on both sides depending on which time
you catch me interestingly one of the
one of the kind of Baptist light
churches Church of the Brethren the left
wing of the Reformation because we don't
believe in sacrament supposedly we
believe in ordinances notice that Jesus
did three things at the Last Supper and
don't worry about the fact that two of
them were in the Synoptics and one of
them in John so when they do Lord's
Supper they do cup bread and foot
washing and is is John is John proposing
an alternate way of remembering him or
is he simply adding to what's already
there or is this doing something ethical
without any liturgical consequences
whatsoever that's my first question
so I'm answering your question with a
question sometimes I think that he's
already given us the bread from heaven
and the true
vine and that we're going to have water
and and and blood at the on the cross
and so he doesn't need to put it in here
because implicit behind the whole story
is a kind of sense that life is lived
sacramentally and i go that still
doesn't stop me puzzling okay but why
not also here this looks like the place
where you could bring all that together
in ways that would be consistent with
tradition and with his own theology I
don't see any particular reasons he
should get rid of it mmm-hmm yeah I
think that's right I've had the same
sort of ambivalence about where to come
down on all of this I guess my way of
thinking about it right now hinges on my
belief that John does know the synoptic
and does think that he's able to do a
better job of conveying the significance
of Jesus and his fellow of animals have
done I think he's really intending to
write something like Scripture something
harder to embody the divine wishes and
so many comes to tell the story of the
Last Supper he's confronted with this
problem do I tell what I've already
alluded to back there in Chapter six
with the bread and the bunching the
burlap and stuff that I'll get to again
when I come to describe the the
crucifixion what do I want in some ways
to do what the function of those last
seven stories is in the synoptic Gospels
to convey here in some profound way the
meaning of the death of Christ mhm and
if I focus on the ritual action I may be
distorting the picture I may not be
capturing the full flavor of what I want
to convey I think that's something of
how he was approaching the issue so in a
way for the early reader or listener
they know that other story and then they
say oh yes but here's something we
should here's another way to think about
it that's right you see I think if John
knows the other gun battles and assumes
his readers also yeah that's what I'm
wondering yeah then he's probably
playing on their expectation that
there's going to be an account of the
last hour here an account of a the
ritual that they never perform in some
fashion
and they're going to be struck by its
absence which is what he does with the
Old Testament that's vanity said we're
gonna start in the beginning or we're
gonna have the banner and is they think
they know other stories going and then
it switches on them mm-hmm yep so it's
another case of this genre-bending
so he's bending the synoptic genre in a
very significant way so what do you have
instead of they the breaking of the
bread you have this symbolic prophetic
action of Jesus where he Gerdes himself
like a like a slave you know he takes
the position of a slave ooh now that has
resonance doesn't it if you think the
absolutely - Paul famously olympians the
talks about the Incarnation and death of
Christ talking about him as being in the
form of God but not consider equality
with God something to be held onto but
instead emptying himself and taking the
form of a slave and dying dying a death
on a cross another one of these many
points of comparison and content
possible contact between John and the
Pauline tradition so Jesus here takes
the the demeanor and they the function
of a slave and this is why I mean
there's a status reversal going on the
disciples don't want him hugely yes
absolutely don't that's why I come to
trial seeing the father weep don't do
that that reverses our roles you're
supposed to be strong that's right yeah
so there's there's an interesting
verisimilitude that reflects the kind of
social structures in both Jewish and
greco-roman society within which this
would have worked so the disciples don't
want to see Jesus they that and you've
been pushing in our conversations all
along the sort of cost of discipleship
and this is another case where it's
coming at you with your very strong way
so Jesus then engages in the the foot
washing and then you have this curious
dialogue with Jesus and Peter where
Peter finally accepts ya foot was
resistant ly resist it but finally
accepts it and Jesus tells him about
being washed and just having to be
tidied up in effect yeah so there's
probably some allusion here to the the
baptism of all I would think yeah
yeah even though that hasn't happened
for the disciples in a narrative way but
again this is one of those cases we have
to transfer into they the story world
things that are coming from the real
world are they the evangelists and so
he's saying this there's something
beyond the baptismal experience the
baptismal experience is good it's
foundational it's basic but there's
something a little bit more than that
and the more has to do with the example
of Jesus yeah and so finally what this
is all about and that's right here on
the surface of the text you don't have
to invoke any special knowledge or a
special theory Jesus says he's giving an
example absolutely an example of self
giving service so if we're right that
this story functions in John in a way
similar to the fashion in which the Last
Supper stories function in the synoptic
Gospels that's pretty critical and John
is saying I can I can make that function
work better by showing ya that Jesus is
an example of self giving sales and if
that's right then I think we begin to
get the solution to the problem of what
the content of Revelation is in John the
content of Revelation as we heard from
way back in chapter 3 and seeing Jesus
the Son of Man like the serpent hung up
on a cross has to do with the the cross
event everything has been pointed at oh
and and this little story of Jesus
giving his his self giving servile
attention on his disciples also points
forward and it's saying that's what that
cross is all about and if we see that
then we begin to get it yeah and that
and the cross is not only a theological
has not only a theological residence but
in practical residents that is how does
residence how does one live out the
cross not just how does one believe the
cross so that's not an important either
that's right and I think all of the the
major early Christian theologians keep
those things in intimate contact the
objective event of God's interaction
with human human life of human suffering
human sin through Jesus and the way in
which Jesus in his behavior as a human
being exemplifies how one relates to God
we've come to appreciate that so much
more and
in dealing with Paul these days we have
the faith of Jesus Christ is not the
fate that Jesus is the Christ but the
fidelity that Christ himself showed to
God see that the Epistle to the Hebrews
and I think we see it here yeah and here
however it's expressed not so much in
terms of faith but in terms of love yeah
the rapp that John gets partly on the
basis of John 13 is that while like all
the synoptic tradition he believes very
strongly in the love of Christians for
others the others are family others
church others that in Matthew Mark and
Luke you have love of the knee a love of
the neighbor then love of the enemy then
love of the larger world John it's the
love one another do you think that
John's Gospel is finally limited to in
truck community in Fort George love as
the commandment yeah there isn't any
explicit command to love enemies there
is no Sermon on the Mount and this is
why we have a Bible as both John and the
Sermon on the Mount are there to make
sure we have both sides both sides but
insofar as that what we get in John is a
message of love it's reinforced in
several ways some of which could arouse
the same kind of suspicion that you've
just put on the table we have the
example of self giving love for his
friends at dinner here in in John 13 we
have the explicit command to love as he
has loved for later on in the chapter
referring back to that example of
survival but also ahead to they the
cross and then we have the proverb in
John 15 after the vine and the branches
parable where Jesus says greater love
than this hath no manatee then that his
life for his friends
Jana which interestingly enough is a
proper that we find in Greek philosophy
all over the place so it's it's out
there everything so one could read all
of these things in a restrictive way as
remaining only to the the Christian
community but then I think you have to
see this in the light of the whole of
the gospel which from the prologue on
has been talking about God's Universal
salvation yeah yeah his sending of his
son into the cosmos about the world in
order to redeem it and God so loved the
world yeah so the promise is that Christ
dies for the sake of the world not just
for the sake of the church I think
that's right and that's certainly what I
would like to believe
me too